We've already done a lot of the steps required to solve the 3-SAT problem in this course.
We've seen how to represent 3-SAT, the input that is.
We've also seen how to apply preprocessing rules so that it's a bit easier to solve after that,
and these are mainly in problem sets 2 and 4.
Now, what we're going to do is construct a search tree
to find if the given instance has a satisfying assignment.
So, you're going to code up a function solve3SAT
that should return none if the given instance of 3-SAT has no satisfying assignment,
and otherwise it should return that satisfying assignment.
Now, the search tree technique that we're going to use is as follows.
When you take any clause that is not satisfied,
and if all of the variables have already been set,
then there is no possible solution anymore, so simply return none.
Otherwise, we branch into at most 3 cases where in each case a different variable is set
so that the clause can hopefully become satisfied.
The first variable is set so that the clause becomes satisfied
and we don't do anything with the other variables.
The first variable is set so that the clause does not become satisfied,
and the second one is set so that it becomes satisfied,
and then we don't do anything with the third variable.
Finally, the first and second variables are set so that the clause does not become satisfied,
and the third one is set so that it does become satisfied.
These are the 3 possible cases with 3 sets
since there are at most 3 variables in any clause.
Now, you can write any additional functions required to solve this problem
or break this up into sub-parts, and I'd recommend doing that;
it should make this much simpler because it can get to be quite a bit of code here.
So, have fun solving 3-SAT.
I know we've already done a lot of the steps.